the u.s supreme court will hear a major
abortion rights case next fall
the decision could have a huge impact
and effect
on the historic roe versus wade ruling
correspondent david spont has details
tonight from the supreme court
five decades after the landmark roe v
wade decision abortion rights could soon
be rolled back significantly
the court agreed to weigh in on a
mississippi law that would ban the
procedure after the 15-week mark
before viability when a fetus can
survive outside the womb
this is a blatant attack on roe v wade
this is a 50-year
precedent coming out of the supreme
court that has laid down the law
and yet we continue to see an increase
in attacks on roe the white house
responded to the news
with a presidential pledge the president
is committed
to codifying roe regardless of the
the outcome of this case oral arguments
in the case are scheduled for the fall
courts around the country have blocked
enforcement of similar laws
citing roe's precedent when you really
drill down on this public opinion would
be
very favorable towards this
compassionate law that's going before
the supreme court
last summer chief justice john roberts
sided with the liberal wing of the court
in striking down abortion clinic access
restrictions in louisiana
he joined justice ruth bader ginsburg
the court's
strongest champion of abortion rights
ginsburg's replacement amy coney barrett
a devout catholic
who in her personal life has made clear
her anti-abortion stance
though publicly she said her personal
feelings won't mix with work
this case signals hot button issues are
welcome at the court
the justices will soon hear cases on gun
control and executive power
affirmative action and immigration
challenges may soon follow
they're starting to gather momentum and
the
very very conservative majority on the
court is i think
headed in the direction of an absolutely
blockbuster term next next year
the court likely won't make a final
decision on this case until about a year
from now but pro-life americans are
feeling confident brett because three
justices appointed by
president trump currently sit on the
bench brett
have responded outside the supreme court
david thanks hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else